[Music]
hi everyone i'm jeevana hegde a customer
engineer at google cloud and welcome
back to the technical guide for startups
where we are creating a series of videos
for technical enablement to start build
and grow your businesses successfully
and sustainably on google cloud
in our previous video we deep dive into
streamlining your application deployment
and now we're on to the fourth stop
which is all about deploying your
microservices application on google
kubernetes engine in this video we're
going to go over understanding
microservices and kubernetes at a high
level and introduce you to google
kubernetes engine or gke and understand
few of its important features
we will also be looking at a sample
ecommerce application architecture and
see how it would be deployed in the
demonstration section we will finally
end it with the customer success story
of an actual google cloud customer and
wrap up with some actionable next steps
so without any further ado let's get
right on to exploring the google cloud
platform together
imagine you and your teammate have built
out a fairly large complex application
now let's say you're done making some
changes to your part of the application
and your teammate is still working on an
entirely different part of the same
application
wouldn't it be convenient if you could
just test out your changes or even
deploy to the main application while
your teammate continues working on his
part
this sort of panel approach can be taken
if you build out your architecture with
microservices as opposed to monoliths
a monolithic application is a single
unified unit whereas microservices
architecture breaks it down into a
collection of smaller independent units
containerization is a method of
visualization which separates the
applications and services at the
operating level
and microservices uses containerization
to deliver smaller single function
modules that work in tandem to create
more agile and scalable applications
and kubernetes is excellent for
containerization
moving on to kubernetes kubernetes can
be summed up by two things one it's an
abstraction over infrastructure
what i mean by this is that when you
install kubernetes it handles the
compute networking and storage for your
user workloads so you don't have to
worry too much about the underlying
environment and you'll be able to focus
on your application
and secondly kubernetes uses a
declarative format to orchestrate its
containers
what we mean by that is that you tell us
what you want and not necessarily how to
create it kubernetes runs a control loop
to ensure that the current state always
matches the desired state as mentioned
in your configuration files if it
doesn't kubernetes is smart enough to
know what steps to take to keep them in
alignment
it might all seem a little complex in
fact it is but that's where google
kubernetes engine or gke comes in
gke is a managed service for running
kubernetes
gke essentially gives you an abstraction
by providing you with freedom with some
configurations and also manages a lot of
features for your containerized
applications
so when we say manage what we mean by
that is that it manages your auto repair
auto upgrade auto scaling auto
provisioning and regional or high
availability control plane it is also
your amazing site reliability
engineering team
we have two modes in gke standard and
autopilot
standard mode is where you configure the
clusters underlining infrastructure
giving you the node configuration
flexibility
and autopilot mode is a step ahead where
gke provisions and manages your
cluster's underlying infrastructure
including nodes and node pools giving
you an optimized cluster with hands-off
experience
now let's quickly jump on to a
demonstration of configuring different
aspects of a gk cluster in both standard
and autopilot mode we start off by going
to the google cloud console
this is the dashboard
we then move to the navigation menu and
go to the kubernetes engine
i suggest if you're not familiar with
the google cloud console please watch
the getting started on google cloud
video that we have for you in the
description box below just to get a
quick run through of the google cloud
console
and then you can come back and continue
this video
here we already have a few of them
pinned and we're going to go scroll down
and go to the kubernetes engine once you
click on kubernetes engine this opens up
you can then create a cluster by
clicking on create here or here
like we discussed we have standard and
autopilot let's start off with standard
once you click on configure if this is
your first time creating a cluster you
are given a quick tour of what all tabs
to click on and a brief overview of
what's in it i'm going to leave the
cluster name as it is and then i can
choose whether i want a zonal or
regional cluster
i can also specify if i want to give the
default node locations
i can then choose my control plane
version whether i want it to be static
or release channel in release channel
every time a new version is released the
clusters are automatically upgraded
unlike in static when i leave it at
release channel and go here to default
pool you can see that the auto upgrade
and auto release are blurred out this is
because this is automatically taken care
of in release channel now instead if i
go back and select static version and
come back to default pool
you can see that you can choose whether
you want to auto upgrade or auto repair
or not well let me leave it at release
channel as it's a best practice and come
back to default pool
now i'm going to leave my pool name to
default pool as it is
leave the number of nodes as well to 3.
change the minimum number of nodes per
zone to be 1
and maximum to be 3
and just quickly look at the other
configurations and leave them as it is i
can either create my note pool directly
here or go to nodes and change the
configurations of the nodes that i want
in my node pool
i can choose from the different families
here and change my machine type
and maybe i want my machine type to have
let's say 2vcpus and 8gb ram
and maybe i also want my disk to have
better performance so i'm going to
change my boot disk to make it ssd
i'm going to quickly look at the
security tab here leave them all to as
it is
look at metadata in case maybe i wanted
to add some kubernetes label in cluster
i'm going to go to the automation tab
and enable vertical port auto scaling
i could enable auto provisioning here as
well
but i'm going to not do that now
move to the next tab
then here in networking it's picked
default which is my default network
you'll learn more about vbc creation in
the upcoming videos so stay tuned
i can choose whether i want my cluster
to be public or private
then you can see that http load
balancing has been enabled here this is
for external load balancing
you'll learn again more about this in
the upcoming networking video
in the security section here i'm going
to let's say disable my shielded gke
notes
then in metadata here it's the cluster
metadata as opposed to what we saw
previously
then in the features section you can see
a bunch of other features which you can
enable such as cloud logging cloud
monitoring anther service mesh and so
much more
and finally i'm clicking on create for
an actual application you don't have to
run through all of these different tabs
as the default values are already chosen
for you of course you can configure them
yourself as well and there you go we
have a cluster which is created
for configuring an autopilot cluster
it's much more straightforward as you
can see in the tour here it only gives
you one thing that it talks about
as you can see a few of those features
that we saw earlier from the standard
are already taken care of in the
autopilot mode
again i'm going to leave the cluster
name as is and the only option here is
for your cluster to be regional this
ensures high availability at all times
you can choose a region of course
and additionally you have some
networking and advanced options you can
choose whether you want your cluster to
be public or private
let me just drop down the networking
options here
i can choose my network here whether i
want it to be the default one or a
network which i've created
i can also choose my node subnet
there's also a possibility for putting
in different address ranges
if not the defaults are taken
now i'm not going to change anything
here and hide my networking options and
go to advanced options
this gives me a bunch of different
options for the tabs which we had seen
earlier in the standard section
i'm going to leave them all as it is and
click on create
and there you go your autopilot cluster
has been created
did you see how much of a difference
there is simply between standard mode
and autopilot mode now imagine you
didn't have gt and you have to do all
this yourself only using kubernetes
wouldn't it be so much more harder
moving on to my favorite section of this
entire video whether your application is
above out doggy dog boutique or ouch
first aid please healthcare application
you can deploy your microservices
application on gke for the purpose of
this demo we'll be sampling an ecommerce
application with a simple and
straightforward name let's call it
online boutique this sample application
has gotten 11 micro services let's
quickly look at the architecture so we
get a clear picture of what our
application looks like
as you can see it's got a payment
service an email service the front-end
service a separate product catalog
service and so on my point being the
application is broken down and makes the
maintenance debugging scalability so
much more easier in this application the
users access the website through the
internet and they reach the front-end
service
they can then browse the items in the
product catalog
add them to their cart and then purchase
them
in the backend the application accesses
a database
additionally a recommendation service
helps recommend similar products and so
on
this is the basic workflow in terms of
the architecture now let's move on to
the demonstration
as part of this demonstration let's look
at three steps
first let's begin by exploring the code
briefly from the github repository
second let's deploy the application on
gke by the command line interface this
on google cloud is the cloud share
and finally let's test out the
application once we deploy it now
quickly jumping onto the first part
i'm going to the github repository of
the online boutique store
we can go to the source file have a look
at the different microservice files
available here
then let's say i go to the cart service
go to the source file here
and then click on services
we see the c-sharp files here
let me go ahead and open one of these
the cart service c-sharp file
you can see the code here
similarly you can go back and look at
these c sharp files to find the code
respectively in the microservices
we also have a few nodejs python and
java files
this very simple and short run through
was essential so we get an idea to
understand how the code has been broken
down now that we have this in place
let's go ahead and deploy this
application on gke you can deploy the
application through the google cloud
console like how we created a cluster
earlier or we can use the command line
interface here let's go over the latter
to do so simply activate cloud shell and
get started
start off by assigning your project id
to the variable project id now for this
particular project or project id i'm
enabling a few apis
now let's go ahead and clone our github
repository
fun fact you have something very similar
to your github repository on google
cloud itself this is called the cloud
source repositories you can store your
code here just as you do on github so
everything stays on the platform
now let's go ahead and create our
cluster as we already discussed we can
do this either in the standard mode or
autopilot mode here let me go ahead and
use the autopilot mode once we've
created it we then deploy our samples
cluster now let's ensure that all our
pods are ready
once they all show that they're running
we can pick the external ip address so
we can access the website and try buying
an item through the application
now let's enter the external ib address
and test it out
yay we have our website now now we can
scroll through and browse through items
let's add this watch to the cart and see
some product recommendations which i
might like
okay great let's also add this top now
and as we can see this ecommerce
application works perfectly
and that brings us to the end of this
demo
now let's look at a real-world google
cloud customer who benefited from the
google kubernetes engine my2 is a
popular photo editing application which
is a leading image processing and social
media platform in china driven by
artificial intelligence
gke helped my two to simplify the
workflow and reduce the operational cost
by 44
gk's auto scaling features allowed them
to use small machines with a high
bandwidth
gk gave the customers a very high
rendering speed of just a few seconds
which improved the customer experience
and made customers come back to them
additionally my uses and thoughts to
deploy and manage containers all over
the world bigquery to analyze user
behavior and get more accurate user
insights
and firebase which helps them reduce the
split testing time to 50 so that
engineers can roll out new features
faster and gain bigger market share
the senior vice president of my2 talks
about some of the numbers here which i
mentioned earlier they were also able to
automate their infrastructure management
and be much more productive
hopefully that gave you a bit of a nudge
so when are you getting started on the
google cloud platform if this video
interested you to learn more about
containerization gke autopilot vs
standard and when to use which don't
forget to check the suggestions we have
for you in the description box below
and that brings us to the end of the
fourth stop which is the gke video in
the next video you will learn more about
the compute engine and you'll be
learning how to configure compute engine
instances you will also be doing a
sample application deployment and end it
with a customer success story just like
we did in this video
so stay tuned if you're looking into
deploying your applications on virtual
machine instances don't forget to like
and subscribe to our youtube channel hit
the bell icon to stay up to date and
receive notifications every time we post
a new video
bye for now and we will see you very
soon in our next video
[Music]